[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la chaîne
de vulgarisation des instances
politiques
la chaîne qui vous explique en quelques
minutes les détails des instances
politiques françaises aujourd'hui on va
parler du président de la république
mais avant de parler du chef de l'état
j'aimerais vous parler un peu de charles
de gaulle charles de gaulle tout le
monde le connaît il a même donné son nom
à un porte-avions et un aéroport mais
avant d'être un porte avion ou un
aéroport charles de gaulle a été l'un
des hommes le plus important pour la
france 20e siècle et si on s'intéresse à
lui dans cette vidéo c'est parce que
c'est celui qui a mis en place la
cinquième république en 1958 et en
mettant en place la 5ème république
c'est aussi lui qui a façonné le rôle et
les pouvoirs du président de la
république charles de gaulle était un
homme qui a vécu la deuxième guerre
mondiale et il avait très mal vécu
l'incapacité de la france à répondre
rapidement à l'invasion allemande en
pour lui la france avait besoin d'un
homme fort à sa tête capable de réagir
vite avec tous les pouvoirs dont il
aurait besoin au moment où de gaulle
réfléchissez à des réformes
constitutionnelles lui et le comte de
paris s'en voyait régulièrement des
lettres dans lesquelles de gaulle
envisager la restauration d'une
monarchie constitutionnelle
comme on le retrouve dans certains
autres pays d'europe car un roi
représente la stabilité la continuité
l'unité nationale
et c'est à travers le statut du
président de la vème république que de
gaulle met en place cette vision et
malgré que la france soit un régime semi
présidentiel
on parle aussi souvent de monarchie
présidentielle pour décrire la vème
république
le rôle du président est décrit dans le
titre 2 de la constitution
et dès les premières lignes on peut lire
que le président de la république veille
au respect de la constitution
il assure par son arbitrage le
fonctionnement régulier des pouvoirs
publics ainsi que la continuité de
l'état
il est le garant de l'indépendance
nationale de l'intégrité du territoire
et du respect des traités
on retrouve dans cet article
tout ce qui représente le président au
sein de la vème république la continuité
de l'état l'indépendance nationale
l'intégrité du territoire
le président est vu comme un homme au
dessus des partis qu'on ne peut pas
juger
il peut gracier à titre individuel et
possède à pouvoir extrêmement étendue et
ce qui légitime cette vision c'est le
fait que le président est élu au
suffrage universel direct par l'ensemble
des français comme il est choisi par
l'ensemble des français
il n'est plus simplement le chef d'une
majorité ou d'une opposition mais
devient le président de tous il incarne
la france
c'est pour ça par exemple qu'on retrouve
le portrait officiel du président dans
toutes les mairies de france est l'une
des principales façons pour le président
d'incarner la france est d'être le super
diplomate français il porte les valeurs
de la france à travers le monde
sa parole ses actes engage la nation il
négocie et ratifie les traités accrédite
les ambassadeurs des puissances
étrangères et les ambassadeurs étrangers
sont accrédités auprès de lui lors de
sommets comme le g8 g20 le sommet
afrique france où le conseil européen le
président entretient des relations
directes avec les chefs d'état et les
gouvernements étrangers
mais il n'est pas aussi facile que ça de
se présenter à l'élection présidentielle
il faut bien sûr avoir 18 ans bénéficier
des droits civiques et on ne peut
exercer plus de deux mandats à la suite
mais ce n'est pas tout il faut aussi 500
signatures d'élus locaux provenant d'au
moins 30 départements différents
avec 50 signatures maximum par
département ses 500 signatures
permettent de valider la légitimité d'un
candidat sur l'ensemble du territoire en
tant que garant de l'indépendance
nationale de l'intégrité du territoire
et du respect des traités
le président possède énormément de
pouvoir notamment d'un point de vue
militaire
le président de la république et le chef
des armées il préside les conseils et
les comités supérieur de la défense
nationale et c'est pour ça que si lui
qui donne l'ordre d'engager
l'utilisation de l'armé nucléaire
la défense est un domaine qu'il partage
avec le premier ministre
il lui est quand même arrivé de
commander seul comme lors de la première
guerre du golf où le président
mitterrand dirigeait les opérations seul
laissant aller car le premier ministre
et le ministre de la défense pour
assurer le fonctionnement régulier des
pouvoirs publics et la continuité de
l'état
il possède aussi d'autres pouvoirs des
pouvoirs exceptionnels les pouvoirs de
crise
en fait en cas d' attaques de la france
de guerre de crise ou de catastrophe
naturelle majeure qui portent atteinte
aux institutions aux territoires aux et
l'est de la france où à la nation dans
une mesure qui interrompt le
fonctionnement normal des pouvoirs
publics le président peut je cite
prendre les mesures exigées par ces
circonstances
après consultation officielle du premier
ministre du président de chacune des
deux assemblées et du conseil
constitutionnel en clair durant cette
période
le président exerce tous les pouvoirs et
ses décisions sont seulement soumise
pour avis au conseil constitutionnel
encore une fois la mise en place d'un
tel pouvoir par le président de la
république est dû en partie à
l'expérience de la défaite face aux
allemands que de gaulle a vécu en 1940
ces mesures doivent permettre un retour
à la normale le plus vite possible du
fonctionnement des pouvoirs publics les
pouvoirs de crise dont été utilisé
qu'une seule fois en 1961
pendant cinq mois par de gaulle pendant
la guerre d'algérie lors de la tentative
de putsch militaire à alger le président
n'a cependant pas qu'une influence
internationale au niveau national aussi
son pouvoir est très grand
c'est lui qui nomme les membres du
gouvernement le premier ministre et les
ministres le président la république
préside le conseil des ministres où il
signe les ordonnances et les décrets
pour finir le président a aussi un lien
fort avec le parlement tout d'abord
c'est le président qui promulguent les
lois donc qui constate que la loi a bien
été adoptée par le parlement et lui
permet d'entrer en vigueur avant de
promulguer une loi
le président peut se quinze jours
demander au parlement une nouvelle
délibération de la loi ou de certains de
ses articles le président la république
peut dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
une fois par an après consultation du
premier ministre et des présidents des
assemblées
enfin en cas d'absence du président de
la république c'est le président du
sénat qui assure intérêts et bien voilà
c'est fini pour cette vidéo j'espère que
vous en aurez appris un peu plus sur le
président la république
si vous avez aimé n'hésitez pas à
partager et à mettre un pouce en l'air
vous pouvez le retrouver sur notre page
facebook et sur notre page twitter à
très bientôt
[Musique]